حيث الازمات السمه المنطقه تاريخيا تختلف
اسباب التصعيد في كل مره تحديدا في
السنوات الاخيره لكن اساسها يبقى برفض
الصرب الذين يشكلون اغلبيه سكان شمال
كوسوفو اعلان الاقليم الاستقلال عن صربيا
الذي تم عام 2008 هذه المواجهات مستمره
منذ ثلاثه ايام بتجمع مئات من الصرب امام
حكوميه في بلده سفيكان الحدوديه مع صربيا
لمنع رؤساء بلديات البان منتخبين حديثا من
دخول مباني البلديات لبدء مهامهم قوات من
بعثه حفظ السلام التابعه للناتو اشتركت مع
شرطه كوسوفو في التصدي للمحتاجين ومحاوله
حمايه مبنى البلديه في وسط سبيكان
وخلال المواجهات العنيفه اصيب عشرات من
جنود بعثه حفظ السلام الدوليه
ادين بشده الهجمات التي تعرضت لها قوات
حفظ السلام في شمال كوسوفو والتي ادت الى
اصابه 30 منهم بجروح هذه الهجمات غير
مقبوله ويجب ان تتوقف رئيس وزراء كوسوفو
البن كورتي دافع عن الاجراءات التي
اتخذتها حكومته في بلديات شمالي كوسوفو
لا اوافق بشكل اساسي على مشروع القانون
بالسماح بقدر اكبر من الحكم الذاتي
للبلديات الذاتي الاغلبيه الصربيه في
كوسوفو
في الاثناء اعلن الرئيس الصربي ان 52
صربيا اصيبوا في الاشتباكات مجددا للتاكيد
على وضع قوته في حاله تاهب على الحدود مع
كسوفه تطورات المنطقه التي يخشاها الغرب
دفعت منطق السياسه الخارجيه للاتحاد
الاوروبي بمطالبه كسوف وصربيا بوقف
التصعيد الذي وصفه بغير المقبول من جانبها
دعت روسيا حليفه صربيا التاريخي الى
التوقف عن القاء اللوم على الصرب الذين
يسعون سلميا للدفاع عن حقوقهم او وفق
قولها مطالبه بخطوات في وقف التصعيد حنان
المصري العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات